this is from the daily beast it's good
that i spent time really trying to find
this story because this is an important
one britney spears lashed out monday at
her son jaden federline uh who recently
criticized her in an interview and said
that he will see her again when she's
better mentally in an instagram
recording the singer accused jaden 15
and his brother preston 16 of abandoning
her saying that they always ended their
visits early and spent the time together
sleeping or playing piano
spear says it saddens me that not one of
you has valued me as a person she's
talking to her own children here on
social media by the way um
said spears who's been locked in a very
public battle with her parents sister
ex-husband and uh other family members
since she convinced the court to end a
conservatorship that stripped her of her
rights
she says quote i don't believe in god
anymore because of the way my children
and my family have treated me i'm an
atheist y'all
now i mention this because i i vaguely
sort of followed the britney spears saga
and not because i'm interested in
britney spears but because i'm
interested in what all of this says
about people in general
and it says a lot about people that
britney spears
can claim that her her entire family
including her children are victimizing
her
this is what she's claiming everyone
around her it's like every week there's
another headline of another member of
britney spears's family or friend or
something that's she's she's attacking
and the media's attacking too how dare
you be so mean to poor britney
the media eats it up the public buys it
seems like
uh and does this even though it's
extremely clear
that she's a mentally unstable
narcissist and she's the common
denominator in all of these situations
so this is the fascinating thing to me
when i see all these people who
buy into the britney spears story she's
a victim and all the rest of it well
have you people not met people
i don't understand this is what boggles
my mind is is is
when you
come across
people
who don't seem to know how people work
like but you are a person
and so
as a person having like lived a human
life have you not
noticed that
every single time
when there's when there's someone who
who claims that everyone around them is
victimizing them and is horrible and
mean and oppressing them in every single
case
it turns out that that person is the
problem
okay if you can't maintain a
relationship with anyone in your life
including your own children
you've got to start looking for the
common denominator which is you
now look there are exceptions to every
rule so maybe there's an exception here
there might be a few people out there
who go around claiming that that
everyone's out to get them and that
they're oppressed by everyone and their
whole family and ever and it's actually
true like there may be cases like that
maybe in theory but
if you don't know much about the
situation and we don't know much about
the situation here because we don't know
any of these people all you read is the
headlines
and so you have to make assumptions
based on
what you know about how people work
and the safest assumption here is that
she's just like this miserable
narcissistic
frankly pretty horrible person
not much of an assumption either because
when you're when you're calling out your
own minor children on social media
that alone pretty good indication that
there are problems and uh and the
problems are mainly with you
now i say all of this but but i'm
starting to realize maybe one of the
part of the problem here is that
those people who are constantly claiming
that everyone around them is is out to
get them
like they don't realize
that they are that sort of person so
maybe all the people that are rallying
around britney spears they are also that
sort of person
they also think that everyone in their
life is out to get them and all the
problems they have in their many
relationship all the many problems they
have in all of their relationships are
always the fault of the other person
never then
[Music]
maybe that explains i don't know it's
possible
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated